boli ou alors les bonnes résolutions
2006 est ce que vous allez arrêter de
fumer
non je vous ai l'air était doux est ce
que vous allez arrêter toute drogue
est ce que vous allez faire un régime
non pas pour quoi faire
est-ce que vous avez non c'est vrai ce
que vous allez faire un septième enfant
oui
dans les contes de fées mal à faire les
sept nains quand même qu'est ce que tu
fais des lettres vient entre coblence et
les messieurs lio est venu mettre un
petit peu d'argent de côté pour l'enfant
pour le septième au moins j'ai tellement
dette j'ai plutôt les rendre ton oui
d'ailleurs excusé moi oui absolument
je signale que toutes les ventes de mon
disque dit au prince charmant sont
reversés à une fondation qui s'appelle
sauver les enfants de lio donc acheter
ce disque qui vous prépare minier parce
que franchement pas à m'aider énormément
alors en 2006 il faudra me lancer une
opération pièce blanche je brûlais là
parce que les pièces jaunes vous les
filets à madame chirac ce qui reste dans
votre poste de monnaie nous les filets
lio se débrouillent sans sens là où
c'est vraiment où ça va c'est bon pour
les petits et bien géré je viens tu sais
mais je sais et je vais tomber amoureuse
est ce que vous aller baiser comme une
folle d'assises ou bien est-ce que vous
allez reprendre le cinéma voilà je vous
allez faire des concerts ouais si vous
avez changé de coiffure
non ce que vous avez vous aimé des
perruques a comme moi est-ce que vous
avez vous réconcilier avec quelqu'un je
me reconstruis avec tout le monde moi
moi j'ai pas de rancoeur je connais pas
ça est ce que vous allez tirer un trait
sur certaines personnes pas et se tire
un trait tout seul elle-même alors du
coup j'ai plus travaillé à faire oui est
ce que vous allez corriger certains
défauts mais qu'est ce que j'ai comme
défaut thierry aucun yo ma voix la
narration comparables sur qui on est
ils ont plié à la haye ce que vous avez
à la chirurgie esthétique mais pas
besoin en même temps pas je pourrai
s'ils avaient besoin comme tout le monde
mais non ça m'emmerde
c'est long c'est douloureux puis on a
puis on appâte enfin vente comme j'ai
pas le temps pour ça est-ce que vous
avez couché les animateurs télé
ah non non
on sent belle qu'est ce qu'il ya comme
boîte de cul dans le 17e open formidable
alors je vais vous raconter une anecdote
secondes
non parce que c'est quand même un des
trucs les plus humiliants qui me soit
arrivée de ma vie je tournais avec
gérard depardieu la fin de tenu de
soirée
gérard était en gare sont en cuir un
petit peu hyper maquiller moi j'étais en
travelo mais comme c'était comme c'était
entre deux prises
quand il y avait du temps de réglage
j'avais pas ma perruque et j'avais des
moonboots où ma jument et gérard ivre
mort
maudit le mien je vais t'emmener dans un
an une boîte sympa la voir là il ya un
truc très sympa où on a tourné avec le
maurice pialat là tu vas voir c'est
vachement bien l'endroit bien avec moi
ils ont gérard il était déjà un petit
peu avancé je me suis dit on récupérera
jamais il au nom gérard on va pas aller
si tu vois c'est une boîte à partouze
que ce un patois nom gérard j'ai pas mes
viendront alors il part et il part tout
seul et je me dis on va jamais retrouvé
donc je lui file le train on arrive une
rue tout à fait anonyme une porte
cochère d'immeubles très 17e l'ats une
porte avec une entrée d'immeuble normale
et une petite porte dans le hall de
l'immeuble en face de l'ascencion petite
porte avec un judas donc tout ça sont
très très bons l'échangisme
gérard s'accroche de la sorte sonne et à
ce moment là un monsieur descend de son
appartement
17e pas du tout et joris tu nous vois
tous les deux noah en jupe
cette petite thierry mugler qui valait
si bien avec les bimbos les fossiles
maquillée comme un luxe en perruque
gérard en cuir et ils nous regardent il
nous fait vous allez là c'est coquin
je me suis dit il est parti je me
souviens composé de honte mais là
l'expression vous allez là c'est
qu'aucun dans le genre ils sont ensemble
ils vont s'envoyer en l'air lui en
travelo avec des moonboots c'est ça a
été de l'humiliation ma vie